you know I think the secret to a Tony
loves cheesesteak is that we took it on
a very low temperature what I like to do
is slowly cook the ribeye to get all the
juices out of it if you cook it on too
high of a temperature you kind of put a
crust on it now for a thick steak that's
good but for a thinly sliced ribeye you
want it low and slow is much better
you'll extract all that flavor from it
I'd rather have you wait five minutes
for a steak but get it right and get it
really juicy then get it in a minute and
then it's overcooked and it's kind of
dry I definitely don't want to drop my
thing is to make sure that when you bite
this steak that that juice just pours
all out the bottom of that roll so now
as you can see this is almost done with
these steaks once the red is out the
steak is finished and the quicker you
get it off the better that steak will be
that I don't even salt this steak until
it's done
so this steak is literally I'd say a
minute away from being finished as you
can see it's a beautiful color and now
we're going to salt it and the reason we
don't salt it is that salt will extract
moisture from me when you have a thick
piece of steak you salt because you want
that crust but with this it's deadly it
will take all the juice out of the state
and you wind up with a very dry piece of
steak all right so now you also notice
that I've incorporated the onions and
the hot peppers right into this because
what I want to do when you get the
cheese next what I want to do is
incorporate
all of those flavors I don't want you to
bite a sandwich and then taste the steak
and then onions and then hot peppers I
want to make one one flavor out of the
steak they're going to also notice that
I do this as well which I flip it right
on the cheese now what this does also is
it takes all of those flavors and
completely incorporates it inside that
cheese so when you take that bite you're
getting hit with every flavor at one
now if you notice all of that cheese is
kind of bubbled in between all of that
meat so now we're going to take it off
and we lay it on see that look at that
that is what a steak is supposed to look
like I mean you can tell just by looking
at it that all of those flavors are all
incorporated together you know and you
get the juice from that you don't want
you don't want to oil you want juice so
that is juice coming out not oil and
that is a cheese steak